I want to talk about you as a group
first what was the idea exactly the idea
was I wouldn't have had the idea without
having had a child you know and my
concern for her was if she grows up to
do music like she'll most likely do if
she chooses to operate in country I
would hope that it would be easy or
easier you know better what could I do
the question was what could I do in any
kind of way small way try to help and
help your daughter merci make it in
country if she want to do I mean you
know I thought the goal is to just try
it because at least I can sleep at night
if that if I've done what I could do
yeah man then Dave Cobb
you know said you need to talk to Brandi
about this and I eventually did and now
it's it's like totally comfortable with
this everybody drive the ship yeah so
she came he were you the next
participant in this yeah yeah I was it
was like I was playing a show at Bassman
East in Nashville yeah she came walking
right up to me with a cocktail and she's
like I want to start a band called the
high woman with you and I was like I
love that name like and I've been
wanting to do something like this for a
really long time like let's talk about
this more and over the course of you
know several months to a year of the
idea unfolded and took shape and we
started talking about how to include
other women and how to make it into less
of a less of a band and more of a
movement that's a big idea it's a big
idea it's kind of is it a scary idea in
some ways I mean when you when you're
grabbing for something that big and
you're because I mean you love music
that's easy yeah this is bigger than
that I don't think it's scary when
you're in a group yeah
that's the thing isn't it yeah we all
were scared when we started to hear the
mixes cuz we were like oh god this is
this is gonna be something I know I was
like I like my life the way that it is
well you made a pretty big entrance
yesterday that was like whoa this could
actually be kind of be mm-hmm
yeah stories you know and perspectives
that we want to get out there and I
think we're representing a lot of folks
that feel like they need to have theirs
well that share the same stories and you
know the a lot of the music on the radio
tends to be love songs or needy songs or
take it away brain bag it is very it was
electric yesterday it was like they were
waiting for us and they wanted to hear
what we had to say which was scary
because we're like I hope you'd like
what we have to say yeah but I also felt
very confident and you know what we have
so much to say as women and and it's not
all roses and and glory if their guts
and glory but it's it's definitely we
have our families there's just so many
there's a lot of hilarious things with
that go along with it so when you say
you want to start a movement a movement
to accomplish what I think it's really
the old Chinese proverb that says that
women hold up half the sky they also
tell the story of half of the human race
and when that's not represented in the
arts than half of our stories aren't
getting told to our to our little girls
and I think that that's not a temporary
or a menial problem that's a really big
problem the arts help us define
ourselves and they definitely define our
childhood and so I think that while the
movement concept is a little bit scary
and we know we're gonna be open to
criticism and we're not perfect women
that it's more of than necessary for
women and young girls that listen to
rural country music Americana music and
roots music mmm you kind of get you're
trying to you're trying to get this
music on the radio
well yeah why not right I mean there was
a time when you could not say that and
have anybody do anything other than roll
their eyes and say good luck but you
know why not let's do it that's true
well you've all tried to get on country
radio Wow one of us is not a 1 everyone
but it's it's not easy is it for a woman
no no but you know what like no one gets
a free pass on country radio I mean Luke
Combs Tim McGraw all those people have
to do radio stuff too
so it's not just the women but I mean I
do think there's maybe more pressure as
a woman and radio to be like extra sweet
and accommodating to these program
directors which is kind of unfair but I
don't know like I've been the most
played woman on country radio the last
two years and I don't know why me and
not some other women amazing women that
are making first of all because you're
very good and you work very hard but it
can't be overstated how important and
how significant it is that's someone who
is succeeding at this goal someone that
is doing well decides to step aside put
herself aside and join a group that says
no it actually is a problem though that
more women aren't doing well and that is
like I think really noble thing and
something that I admire you so much for
well it's lonely like to be I don't know
like I want to celebrate my number one
obviously and I'm very proud of it I'm
not trying to diminish but I definitely
it's bittersweet because so many of my
friends have to do all the same work
I've done and can't get like a single
spin so I mean I'm hopeful that it's
changing for the better
but yeah joining this band in the midst
of this song girl like on country radio
was it was this is like a very soul
nourishing thing for me not that my own
solo endeavor is not but I am I
definitely am I feel very fortunate to
be
in this band right at this time even if
it is chaos with our schedules just one
thing you know we've got a lot of colors
that we like to send through the
universe in our music like I know I do I
like to do a certain type of yeah well
it's nice to have other other chapters
but you all have very busy other lives
kind of had to put aside for this which
when you when you talked about it's a
little scary
what happens if it what happens if this
gets big I'm just Cinderella of the
group I'm the one who I'm like when is
midnight gonna strike that is that that
is the hard part about all of this is
figuring out everyone's schedules but I
feel like you know what if you guys you
guys just you can work it out and we
hope to just honor it out of the
movement honor the gift and honor all
the other women that we feel need their
stories to be heard it's already big to
me because it's happened like yeah right
that's a big deal what does it feel like
to you I mean you all have been on stage
and you know what it's but what does
this feel like this sitting here last
night yes what is that what is actually
doing it now feel like for me it was
out-of-body was like I've never been
somewhere where people stood the whole
time and we're clapping and cheering
we're just so excited that we were all
there but it was so fun being with my
friends but it was also very nervous
very nervous the people worried yeah
musicians were in it in so much I think
and I key I always say this that that
it's just it's a relationship that that
symbiotic I guess you know we're all
reciprocating with one another and it
makes it even bigger and suddenly you're
doing this big thing that's music and
it's alive for this one
and some sort of such like that I like
sharing the stage with these three
because you know we've all have our solo
careers which I've really only done
I mean I've I've done since I was 10
I've never been in a group setting on
stage unless it's like I don't word show
tribute or whatever so I really have
loved like looking to my left and my
right and knowing that they've got me if
anything happens so I think that was
probably the most surprising thing
yesterday so like very communal to last
things when together there's a tattoo
involved in being part of this yes this
group it's not you can be a high you
don't have potato your necklace is made
my best friend is the jeweler and we've
had the highwayman necklaces but I was
like I don't do that to as I can do you
got the tattoo on my neck yes what's my
name that's on the back here yeah I want
to get a pineapple tattoo today really
strong no and last you have you have a
surprise guest for this set which I
gather I gather she says you're
responsible I probably am I wrote a lot
of letters are we like to talk about it
so our special guest tonight what is she
wearing I know is Dolly party said he
just gonna run guy don't look at that
stuff okay she can't be she did come
into the sheiks because she did come in
in a like a shawl it was pretty funny
yeah she really wants it to be a secret
I'm really excited about it the way
we're gonna introduce her is gonna make
me cry why because we're gonna introduce
her with a really powerful statement
we're all gonna join in four-part
harmony and say she's an eagle when she
flies before we introduced Dolly and
then we're gonna bring her out and she's
gonna address Newport it's gonna be
historic because you know since 1959
this festival has a legacy of just
incredible history of civil rights and
and huge moments and the first female
all female headlining set at Newport on
its 60th anniversary is gonna be with
the highwayman and Dolly Parton and Judy
Collins and some of our way papers it's
going to be really special moment mm-hmm
and what do $1 what did you want what
did you want Ellie I wanted dolly
because I feel like she has been the
consummate and ultimate feminist but
beloved by all different kinds of people
all they see when they look at dolly is
her heart that's all you see you know
there's the clothes and the boobs and
the outlandish statements and the nails
the one-liners and the songs and and all
these things but you know you really see
Dolly's heart right on her sleeve and I
don't think that there is a bigger star
or a more prominent woman to guide and
be our guiding light yeah you whenever
she asked me to be in a band Brandi and
she I was like well I don't really know
what this means she goes well we're
working on getting to sing with dolly at
Newport and I was like I'm in she's been
very serious about she's been really
nice what's this whole time but when the
dolly thing happened she's like don't
you screw this up for me you guys remove
this for me I'm
you don't want to mess but I still I'm
like waiting with bated breath because
until she walks on stage tonight I still
don't feel like I believe it's happening
so unbelievable so it's some of you sang
with her before ya know you have a tude
really I did it the Grammy tribute right
that's right yeah yeah yeah so she and I
are oh yeah
[Laughter]